so nice to be here it's putting my show
thank you I told you a million times big
deal so you're very lovely but our first
time we ever met I have to tell you all
was it Hollywood game night and this is
what anyway loved her cuz she legit
walked up to me we've never met I think
I know she walked up and like got this
ghoulish ghost
Kelly Clarkson I did not come here to
lose she was so one of the battle bit
makes me sweat thinking about it I don't
even I haven't even watched it I feel
like a petition yeah well cuz I'm anyway
he did win I'm Edwin yes yeah I get
annoyingly competitive I get it - no
it's not that cute yeah no well we have
a clip of a few of our finer more watch
them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just
my crazy but we won and we're and you
want us on your team exactly right
unless you want to lose so yeah but I
did I had so much fun that night with
you I had literally felt like we were
kinder trees I'm a little more extra
than you which I'm sorry it's a lot to
you know I know I think I scared Jane
Lynch but well I'm gonna find her and
we're gonna make up but I thought we had
so much fun playing one of the games so
I thought I know we were on a team
together but it might be fun if we play
against each other
maybe our team won maybe to see who the
weakest link is I don't know but later
in the show we're gonna do you know what
bring it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
see you play games with your kids yes
yeah for sure if you ever played one
night ultimate werewolf wait what
one if you all played it it's okay no so
much fun one one night ultimate werewolf
super fun I don't really understand the
point it's all about trying to catch
each other in a lie and my kids are so
good at it I feel like why am i teaching
them the skill but I would suck at that
game bad yeah I have no filter no no
clearly that would miss really fun
codenames is really her name's it's good
that's good I get very competitive at
roles which Jane thought I cheated on
Hollywood game night did not know I was
cheating I thought we were allowed to
tell each other well thank God you told
me we wouldn't have won if you don't
know the rules it's not cheap exactly I
said oh I think she thinks I'd [ __ ]
whatever whatever we'll make up wait we
will I'm gonna find her I'm gonna hunt
her down like I'm hunting Meryl um but
we're on where in the world like on this
planet do you have time to like garden
cook prep do all the stuff like you're
so into car I am too but I don't have a
ton of time like how do you find the
time and do your kids eat your food they
well the harder you work on a meal the
less likely they are to eat it yeah have
you ever noticed that when you've really
sweat and you've really tried something
new
and that's when they're just like I'm
not hungry thanks which is the code for
I don't like it but I'm not really
hungry I'm okay I had apples and you
just feel like yeah but if you throw
something together then you know that's
literally every parent you just
described at mealtime like I like such
in my three old son I'm like seriously
like it doesn't matter what I put I
could put apples in front of and he
loves it and then the next day he's like
I hate apples right right right I mean
the trick is to care less don't wear
caring on your face yeah and don't try
your nice shall on your yes I don't care
if you whatever I mean I made homemade
pasta it's time it took me three hours
yeah it's like eat it or not it's fine
doesn't matter
yay good night honey yeah sure
yeah everything's fine yes they do
sometimes now that they're getting older
they're starting to eat more yeah
so where did once upon a farm come from
cuz we actually have in our household
that's no light if you love it so glad
when my kids were babies I went to the
store I was a working mom the first
thing that I opened it looks like cat
food baby food in a grocery store it's
been sitting on the shelf for ever and
again sit there like longer than a
Twinkie and it's been everything's been
cooked out of it just doesn't even make
sense so I knew there had to be a new
and a better in a different way and I
found
Cassandra Curtis and Ari Roz and they
were doing this amazing different way of
making baby food just using technology
and cold pressing it yeah so that you
don't cook the nutrients out it has all
the fiber and the flavor and the colors
and the vibrancy of item and a lot of
people don't know what that is but yeah
it keeps all of that stone yeah so what
it does is it puts its like put it you
you put it under the pressure of nine
oceans basically the weight of nine
oceans is what they say on my uniform
right I wasn't raised on a farm my mom
was raised on Oklahoma that's an
Oklahoma and it is now it's our family
farm and now it's growing produce for a
Once Upon a farm that is so good it's
like you don't care about yourself but
for some reason when you start
procreating you're like wait what's
going in them well you know what's funny
is that you've got you talked to friends
and they say my dog is eating human
grade food I mean my dog you could eat
the food that my dog eats it's in a
cooler at the grocery store and then
meanwhile we go and buy baby food and
it's mush and that's what we're used to
it doesn't make sense it's not with no
color that's like the worst for them
like when it's all just like beige right
they're like no green and I'm like okay
cool and then I hide it in a sippy cup
so it's great weekend we offer all the
recipes for anything that we do so you
can because we always have a great hero
ingredient like tumeric okay that's cool
or max or all kinds of different things
to them we always have something great
in there for brain development or
whatever and so we offer the recipes if
you can make it great if you can't we've
got you covered I
my husband died since we moved out here
our farm is in Tennessee it's a little
rough commute so um so we're selling
that and we bought a ranch in Montana
because of you you were talking man Tina
we're going on Colorado but we bought
this ranch and we're doing all the
subsidies say I love to be like you you
inspire us to just say today and you're
hilarious because I follow you online
and you talk to your chickens and you
sing to your bees you do all this crazy
so what are you gonna do you have stood
by no you knock your chickens yes what
are like maybe a couple names of your
chicken that was Captain Hook oh hi
chickens
Oprah henfrey's next we have hennifer
and then we're gonna do Ellen DeGeneres
okay Oprah henfrey's just throwing this
out there but Kelly Clarkson is good to
[Applause]
mine hennifer I will for sure they don't
have a preference you want to be an
olive Egger do you want to be I want to
be the craziest chicken I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this